How old was Rebecca when she got married
to Isaac?
>> How old do you think?
>> It says three years old.
>> Show me the verse.
>> I'm reading it.
>> Yeah,
>> I'm pulling it up. Genesis 24 right now.
>> For sure.
>> Yeah. So, I'm searching for that verse
uh so that I can tell you. But
>> Okay. I I'll
>> Yeah. Give me one second. Let me look
for it real quick. But
>> doesn't that mean you're glorifying
Jesus over God? Because Jesus himself
said Yeah. Because if Jesus himself said
the father is greater than he was,
>> why are you glorifying him over God?
Like over
>> Oh no, we glorify them equally. We say
Yeshua Akbar, we say the father Akbar,
we say holy spirit Akbar because they
are one and the same. But then uh
somebody came up to him and then he
asked him what was the greatest
commandment and they Jesus said the
greatest commandment is all you is
Israel your god is one god that was his
time for him to
>> yeah put out the trinity and he didn't
put out trinity
>> that is the trinity the trinity is one
god that's what the trinity is
>> no but my my my question is like so at
that time when Jesus was asked that
question
>> I need you to get that verse
Father, God, and the Holy Spirit. That
was his chance. But he didn't
>> He said Father, he said Father He said
Father, Son, and Holy Spirit in Matthew
28:19.
>> That's where he said it
>> when he was telling people to go and uh
baptize people.
>> Yep. In the name singular, one name of
the Father and of the Son and of the
Holy Spirit.
>> So then the the apostles the apostles
didn't do that.
>> Oh, they did. Not one apostle went
around
>> what
>> uh glor he went like I'm saying
>> that's another that's another thing
that's another thing Jesus mentioned the
father son and holy spirit together did
he not
>> no my my point is when he was saying go
and baptize people
>> I know I know what your point is did
Jesus not reference the holy trinity
father son and holy spirit to go perform
the ritual right of baptism
>> so I'm so
>> it's a Yes or no?
>> I'm going to come back. I'm going to
come back and say that that
>> I can't say that with absolute certainty
that Jesus said that because
>> Okay. So, you don't tell me what Jesus
said or didn't say. Then we can't let's
not even talk about it. Let's get the
verse where Rebecca was three, though.
That's what I need from you.
>> All right. Let me go back on my search
again because I was looking at it, but
then I can't like Genesis 20 25:20. But
>> Genesis 25:20. Let's pull it up. Genesis
25:20. But
>> no, I'm saying it's saying that Isaac
was 40, but it's not saying how how old
um how old Rebecca was.
>> So then where'd you get it from? That I
that Rebecca was three years old.
>> I know I got it from somewhere. I'm
That's what I'm saying.
>> It could be possible that you got it
from some Dagandas lies, right? Some
lies from Gang. Dang. But that's what
you were doing. That's what you were
doing because you put up you pulled up
your verses and you you pulled up your
verses when you said
>> uh Aisha was born I mean Aisha was
married at six but then the marriage was
consummated at nine
>> but then you go back around and saying
that
>> you know uh little girls can get married
but you're not saying that this is a
contract. You're not saying it's a
contract.
>> You're saying they're married and it's
consummated already. And that's my
argument with you because you saying one
thing in one area.
>> I was there. Did the sources that I say
that did the sources that I bring that I
brought up say exactly what I said?
Let's let's start with the Aisha thing.
Did it say exactly what I said it said?
>> The Aisha thing you said Aisha was
married at six and then the marriage was
>> at nine. Did it Did the Did the Did it
say exactly what I said it said?
>> Yes, it did say that. So, so I didn't
lie.
>> You didn't lie. But I'm saying And then
>> So you lying now?
>> Are you lying?
>> Am I lying?
>> Yeah. Are you lying to Rebecca?
>> I'm not lying on Rebecca.
>> But you said that the Bible says she was
three. So notice the difference. I was
able to bring you the exact reference
where Aisha was nine when she when
Muhammad mounted her. Multiple
references. But you can't bring me one
biblical reference that says Rebecca was
three. So did you lie or are you telling
the truth?
Isaac mentioned Rebecca at the mentioned
Rebecca at the age of 40.
This will
Yeah, this I find it right here. I don't
So I don't know if this is uh commentary
or what you know.
>> Am I able to share my screen?
>> I heard I heard I heard what you were
reading. You're reading what? Some
You're on an article, are you not?
>> Yeah, that's
>> Yeah, you're not. You're not. Give me
the Bible verse, even with this
anti-Christian article that you're on.
It's probably a Dagandas. Show me the
verse that says Rebecca was three. What
verse do they use?
>> So, they keep saying it's uh Genesis
20:25, but then I'm like, it's not 2520,
but it's not saying uh it's not
presenting the age. So they're lying,
aren't they? So they're lying, aren't
they?
>> That's not me lying. I don't know if
they're lying or not.
>> Not you. Not you. What? What? Not you.
But this source that's saying that
Rebecca was three and they're
referencing a verse that doesn't say
that. They're lying, aren't they?
>> I couldn't I couldn't say it. But But my
thing is,
>> wait, wait, wait, wait. I I need you.
I'm testing your integrity right now, my
man.
>> Okay.
>> I'm testing your integrity right now.
I'm testing to see if in future live
streams I can continue to bring you on
or else or or or if you're just a waste
of time cuz you're a liar. I'm testing
your integrity.
>> If they're saying
>> I can't say that line because I've heard
this before. I've heard this before and
I just can't pull it up right now.
>> Let's do this.
>> Maybe maybe how about we do this logic.
How about we do this?
And then I do my research when whenever
I like on the future stream I come with
the reference.
>> No, here it is right here. 2520
is what it says right here. I have it on
the screen.
Let me pull it up.
There it is right there.
>> So yeah, that's what I was saying. It's
saying it's saying Isaac's age, but it's
not saying Rebecca's age. And that's
what I was saying. So, if the article
says that this verse says Rebecca was
three, yet we look at the verse and it
doesn't say that, then they're lying,
right?
>> But does that mean does that mean
there's no question that says it?
>> Answer the question.
>> Does that mean this this is the only
verse?
>> Answer the question.
>> You want me to call somebody a lion and
I'm not comfortable saying that, you
know?
That's my
2,200 people, Sally. 2,200 people are
seeing how dishonest you are, the lack
of integrity that you have. But it's not
because, you know,
I it's it's because you're a Muslim,
bro.
It's because you're in Islam. That's the
only reason
is because you have an antichrist
spirit, man.
You can't even admit to lying or making
a mistake. You can't even admit that a
article that you was relying on lied on
a verse of the Bible. You can't even
admit that. So, you are a waste of time.
You have no integrity. Do not come back.